in the late 17th century a medical
student named Johannes Hofer noticed a
strange illness affecting Swiss
mercenaries serving abroad its symptoms
including fatigue insomnia irregular
heartbeat indigestion and fever were so
strong the soldiers often had to be
discharged as Hofer discovered the cause
was not some physical disturbance but an
intense yearning for their Mountain
homeland he dubbed the condition
nostalgia from the Greek nostos for
homecoming and algos for pain or longing
at first nostalgia was considered a
particularly swiss affliction some
doctors proposed that the constant sound
of cowbells in the Alps caused trauma to
the eardrums and brain commanders even
forbade their soldiers from singing
traditional Swiss songs for fear that
they lead to desertion or suicide but as
migration increased worldwide nostalgia
was observed in various groups it turned
out that anyone separated from their
native place for a long time was
vulnerable to nostalgia and by the early
20th century professionals no longer
viewed it as a neurological disease but
as a mental condition similar to
depression psychologists of the time
speculated that it represented
difficulties letting go of childhood or
even a longing to return to one's fetal
state but over the next few decades the
understanding of nostalgia changed in
two important ways its meaning expanded
from indicating homesickness to a
general longing for the past
and rather than an awful disease it
began to be seen as a poignant and
pleasant experience perhaps the most
famous example of this was captured by
French author Marcel Proust he described
how tasting a Madeline cake he had not
eaten since childhood triggered a
cascade of warm and powerful sensory
associations
so what caused such a major reversal in
our view of nostalgia part of it has to
do with science psychology shifted away
from pure theory and towards more
careful and systematic empirical
observation so professionals realized
that many of the negative symptoms may
have been simply correlated with
nostalgia rather than caused by it and
in fact despite being a complex
emotional state that can include
feelings of loss and sadness nostalgia
doesn't generally put people in a
negative mood instead by allowing
individuals to remember personally
meaningful and rewarding experiences
they shared with others nostalgia can
boost psychological well-being studies
have shown that inducing nostalgia in
people can help increase their feelings
of self-esteem and social belonging
encourage psychological growth and even
make them act more charitably so rather
than being a cause of mental distress
nostalgia can be a restorative way of
coping with it
for instance when people experience
negative emotional states they tend to
naturally use nostalgia to reduce
distress and restore well-being today it
seems that nostalgia is everywhere
partially because advertisers have
discovered how powerful it is as a
marketing technique it's tempting to
think of this as a sign of us being
stuck in the past
but that's not really how nostalgia
works instead nostalgia helps us
remember that our lives can have meaning
and value helping us find the confidence
and motivation to face the challenges of
the future
you